[Music]
what are you
focusing on focus is success at sapiens
institute
we are not only focused on producing
books delivering academic workshops
writing essays responding to doubts and
removing misconceptions we are dedicated
to creating and developing intellectual
academic activists
we need people around the world to
academically and
intellectually share the deen so far in
less than a year
we empowered and delivered training to
over 6
000 muslims atheism social darwinism
post modernism
neoliberalism and many other isms
started with an idea
that was developed academically and then
filtered down to the masses
we need our leaders to do the same but
with the truth
be a leader donate now and support this
noble
cause click the button or the link below
and support this nobel course
no